We are given the task of planning a new city.
What would the list of necessities include?
A medical care center, market area, garden,
shopping center, educational institutes
and so many in the list !
Apart from these, the proper supply of water
and a well designed sewerage system
tops the chart of requirements !
are we missing something important ?
For every house to be functioning properly,
don’t we need a power supply ?
Of course yes !
Power supply is one of the most essential requirements
of every home today.
Without it, functioning of important
and useful gadgets is not possible !
Similarly, in our cells,
for the organelles to work,
there has to be a continuous supply of energy.
So which organelle
takes the responsibility of supplying this energy ?
It’s the mitochondria.
The double membrane organelle is called as
power house of the cell because it produces molecules
which are the usable form of energy for the cell.
What do we mean by usable form of energy
in the first place ?
Well, let’s say we want to buy something from a shop.
What will we give the shopkeeper
in return of the goods ?
Can we just give him pieces of paper ?
Of course not !
We give proper currency notes
and not just pieces of paper.
That is because although both are made up of paper,
currency notes are the standardized forms with
immense value.
So we can say that these currency notes
are the usable forms.
If the same sized piece of paper is given,
then that will not be considered as a currency.
Because the usable form is the actual standard
and accepted currency note!
Similarly, the food we eat gives us energy.
We know this.
But the energy from the food is not in the usable form.
So the enzymes in the mitochondria convert
these energy molecules into usable molecules
called the Adenosine triphosphate .
It is abbreviated as ATP .
So are these ATP molecules the usable forms ?
That's Right.
Cells can obtain energy when these ATP molecules
are broken down.
So how does this power house of the cell look like ?
The mitochondria , has two membranes
the outer membrane and the inner membrane.
The outer membrane is PORUOS which means
it allows the TRANSPORT of materials across itself.
The inner membrane is slightly different
and interesting to understand.
The membrane is thrown into several folds
and therefore has a LARGER surface area.
These folds are referred to as “Cristae”.
But what is the use of a larger surface area?
A larger surface area would be a wider base
for ATP generating chemical reactions.
Because the larger area
will harbor more enzymes that will produce ATP .
The inner part of this membrane has a matrix which
contains all the necessary enzymes for ATP production.
Thus, larger the surface area,
larger will be the amount of ATP molecules generated !
Apart from this, the organelle has its own DNA
and ribosomes just like the NUCLEUS.
Therefore mitochondria can make its own proteins
and replicate on its own.
That means make its copies
independent of the other organelles.
Now that we have got introduced to this extremely
important organelle, let us have a look at
one more interesting organelle in the list.
Let us have a look at “VACUOLES ” in the next video!